tell me what plays Trump wouldn't go to  on media where they would trash him  where would he not go to would he not go  to CNN would he not go to MSNBC would he  not go to Jimmy Fallon  he went everywhere right now let me flip  this on you how many times have you seen  Obama  Clinton Hillary any of those guys Biden  go on Fox ever how many times the answer  is never except for once do they do they  do let me make my point here the point  I'm trying to make too is the following  as much as we can say you know whatever  we want to say about guys like a trump  or anybody else if you're willing to go  in the den and know they're going to  trash you no they're looking for their  moment agree or disagree man that's  that's the last thing you can say is  that's a thing a thin-skinned person  won't even go in there